marine qu'est-ce que tu auras dire à
tous les jeunes de ton âge qui nous
regardent qui ont 18 ans
aujourd'hui tu as vécu un drame il y en
a plein qui se reconnaissent en toi ce
qu'ils disent c'est vrai moi il ya plein
de parents qui doivent nous regarder qui
ont une idée reçue chez mes parents des
enfants qui vont sortir ce soir ou
demain je vais je vais je vais être là
je vais avoir la peur au ventre parce
que c'est vrai que ce qui est arrivé à
marine ça peut arriver là nanterre c'est
six mois là puis c'est sur la ccvo lieu
plutôt tranquille inventaire exactement
voilà donc ça fait vraiment flipper
qu'est-ce qu'est ce t'as envie de leur
dire
j'ai envie de dire que
la vie est une rose et malheureusement
il n'ya pas que les pétales il ya aussi
les épines et puis une rue sans épines
ben spies rose
moi je pense qu'il faut la prendre avec
les épines la vie c'est pas grave et
tous les gens qui ont subi ça tu faut en
parler parce que sincèrement parler ça
fait du bien ça fait beaucoup de bien il
faut faire avancer ça il faut faire
qu'on se sente en sécurité
il ne faut surtout pas arrêter de vivre
moi je t'ai d'un mauvais exemple je peux
être arrêté livre un petit moment mais
je reviendrai plus forte après déjà tu
vois ton discours a changé depuis tout à
l'heure c'est ça qui fuse ça fait du
bien de parler ça fait du bien
j'étais bien avec nous ce soir oui
extrêmement bien à une coutume espères
tu reviendras nous voir fente fructueux